Europe Asia Australia South America
everywhere else the private sector is
building a lot China communist China has
way more cases where the private sector
is involved in building roads then the
United States does
I think this poll is is going to be
important and people are going to pay
attention for two reasons one its it's a
good national survey 1200 people a good
demographic mix and geographic mix from
around the country with a good level of
accuracy and we worked very hard to ask
some questions that aren't typically
asked in transportation poll so the idea
is to generate some information that
policymakers can actually use that they
don't usually get the federal government
is allegedly going to do a
transportation bill this coming year it
usually doesn't happen in election year
but there'll be a lot of debate in
Washington about transportation and it's
always an issue for local government the
biggest problems that people identified
is first that for the for the vast
majority of people congestions been
getting worse and they think congest is
going to keep getting worse we've spent
a lot of money on transit in cities in
the last 30 years and in spite of that
the poll shows sort of what we already
knew which is not very many people ride
public transit about two-thirds of
people say that the government generally
doesn't spend transportation money very
well more than half of people say the
transportation system they use is not in
good shape it's a very opaque system
people don't know how much they pay I
mean you ask the average person how much
gas tax they pay and they have no idea
they think the gas tax goes up when gas
prices go up even though it doesn't so
they don't know how much they pay and
they don't know where it's being spent
because there's not a very good system
by which the government says here's
where your tax dollar your gasoline tax
dollars are going people just see that
nothing seems to change their commute
continues to be congested they're not
driving on a new road usually they look
at that and they look at things like the
bridge to nowhere you know which is kind
of a trivial thing in a lot of ways but
it's emblematic it's a poster child for
a system of politicians spending the
transportation money based on politics
rather than how can we make the
transportation system better we ask
people about you know where the
priorities should be four
pretation spending and about two to one
people said we should focus spending on
roads and the highway system because
that's the system that most people use
and that's the system that carries most
of the goods that have to get around you
know our cities and our rural areas
versus spending the money on trying to
get people to stop using their cars and
use some other form of transportation or
stay home or whatever for a long time
we've had this idea that if if we expand
the road system we spend more money on
roads than that those roads just fill up
so if you add lanes to the congested
freeway pretty soon more people to say
oh well the freeway is working better
now so i'll drive on the freeway and it
just gets congested growth and more
people traveling just wreak ingests the
road no matter how much you expand it
and there's some truth to that if you
make travel better more people travel
but more people are traveling so yes you
may get congestion back after a few
years but it's congestion with more
people able to travel so you're still
better off as a community because more
people can get where they want to go and
people have more choices about how to
get there because you have a bigger and
better system what we've been doing for
the last 20 years is investing a lot
more money in public transit than people
who ride public transit so you know in a
typical city a large city in America
you've got something like five to ten
percent of the people riding public
transit but you're spending 25 to 40
percent of the money on it which means
the roads are basically going to pot
because they're carrying ninety percent
of the traffic but only getting sixty
percent of the money the system hasn't
been working and people you know clearly
seem to be saying hey let's have the
resources predominantly go to roads we
asked if people thought we should raise
the gas tax in about two thirds said no
we should not raise the federal gas tax
so and that wasn't a very surprising
result people don't think the money is
being spent well so they're not going to
support raising that fee so we asked
about other choices like if if you're
going to build a new freeway in your
city or ADD lanes to an existing freeway
would you rather pay for that with tolls
or with increased taxes and about
two-thirds of people
said we'd rather pay for it with tolls
and about sixty percent of people said
they would pay a toll on a new road if
it would make their trip significantly
shorter we also asked about
public-private partnerships so basically
having the private sector come in and
and pay for building a new road and
obviously charge people to use it and
and if it's a new road about fifty-five
percent of people supported having the
private sector build new roads if it
makes sense in their city about
one-third of all the new freeway lanes
that have been built in the United
States in the last ten years have been
told so tolling is actually quite a
significant part of how we build new
roads in this country now in the United
States those kind of public-private
partnerships are not really that popular
compared to the rest of the world we've
got a culture of the government owns and
controls the roads and we have trouble
letting go of that and while the rest of
the world is saying you know these
things are like electric utilities and
water utilities you know you got to
regulate them because you don't always
have choices but the private sector can
do it and you can pay to use it the
government is taking a lot of money from
people in taxes to pay for
transportation they've got to do a
better job of being transparent without
where that money is going and being
efficient they're not very efficient
with how they spend it if people see
okay look you know I see where all the
money's going and I see there's no more
money to build this new road I might be
more willing to pay a toll for that road
so it's the the murkiness of the
existing system that creates a lot of
resistance to paying for tolls on new
roads another thing we asked about in
the poll is how much do people trust you
know different government you might not
be surprised that people trust their
local government a lot more than their
state which both of which they trust a
lot more than they trust the federal
government's that's really relevant to
transportation because you know if you
look at our survey results on
transportation specifically there's a
lot of distrust in the government in
general in terms of transportation the
onus now is on the government okay if
they're going to keep the job of doing
transportation they're going to have to
do a better job of it are they need to
bring in the private sector
and get projects done in a way that will
build people's trust because they know
what they're paying and they know what
they're getting the hot idea at the
federal government level for the past
few years and the Obama administration
has been high speed rail that's been
their big transportation push we asked
in our survey whether people think that
if high-speed rail is built should the
government build the high-speed rail
lines between the major cities that are
being talked about or should the private
sector build high-speed rail lines when
they see there's enough people that are
willing to pay for it and about 2 to 1
people said it's better to have the
private sector build it when they see
there's enough customers than to have
the government build it you know without
really worrying about customers in most
cases the federal role in transportation
has really been undergoing a lot of
change for a long time you know in the
60s and 70s we were building the
interstate system and that was all the
federal government and then when they
finished building the interstate system
the federal government still collected a
lot of money and they gave that to the
states to expand the roads and fund a
lot of public transit systems and
maintain the interstates but a lot of it
became kind of pork barrel local
governments have the real problems I
mean our transportation problems are not
that there's not in a freeway from
Oklahoma to Missouri that's not the
problem there's not that there's not
enough freeway you know from New
Hampshire to North Carolina generally
speaking there's enough interstate what
we don't have is enough freeway in DC in
Chicago in Atlanta in Denver you know we
have congestion in those cities because
there's more people traveling than we
have room to travel basically the
government is going to have to figure
out how to do a better job with that
money and prove to people that they're
doing a better job with that money if
they can see the benefit and they can
see their trip getting better they'll
pay a toll and if the private sector has
to build the thing because the
government doesn't have the money and
pay for it with that toll they're fine
with that in a lot of ways
transportation policy making is not
really about providing what the people
want but providing what the government
you know wants to see for outcomes so
they may want to see less travel they
want to see less sprawl you might want
to see less
greenhouse gas emissions and so they say
well we're going to do transportation
spending design to accomplish those
things and the fact that people want a
transportation system that makes it
easier to get places is not really
relevant we've spent a lot of resources
trying to get more people to quit
driving and use public transit or walk
or bicycle we haven't had great results
from that as many people telecommute now
as ride transit or walk or bike or
carpool and so people say hey spend the
money on the system that we all use the
first purpose of the transportation
system should be to provide people with
mobility and then if there's efficient
ways to address other problems in
transportation policy that's worth
considering but you can't put the cart
before the horse